raymond est en vacances à acapulco au
mexique
il compte sur l'assurance voyage de sa
carte de crédit
un soir il sort en ville et acapulco sa
branche parfois et surtout mauvaise
place au mauvais moment et il est blessé
mais il souffre encore plus en voyant sa
facture sur l'assurance voyage ne couvre
pas les soins médicaux
pourquoi parce qu'elles excluent les
régions du monde qui font l'objet d'un
avertissement du gouvernement du canada
ces avertissements sont émises pour
informer les voyageurs de certains
dangers et le gouvernement a alerté les
voyageurs sur la présence du crime
organisé
acapulco plusieurs régions du monde sont
considérées comme dangereuses et cette
liste évolué les voyageurs devraient
donc la consulter souvent
raymond lui et tabac sur dit que s'il
avait su il aurait souscrit une
assurance plus complète le fin mot de
l'histoire
lisez les avertissements et vérifiez que
votre assureur vous assure vraiment